[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
hello welcome
um I'm Andrew Warner one of The
Producers here at the long Mao
Foundation
um first a bit of housekeeping if
everyone can remember to turn off their
phones
um
when we were coming out of the pandemic
we had a moment where we weren't selling
out shows like tonight and
um we sort of put our heads together at
long now to try and figure out why
people leave the house these days and um
one of the reasons we decided was for
people to hang out with other people so
um that was one of The Inspirations for
uh finding this venue and choosing it so
we hope tonight you get a chance to see
some old friends make some new friends
um we're gonna have the venue after the
talk so feel free to order drinks and
stick around and say hi to your neighbor
so when people they come along now
member there's a little like sign up
reason box I don't know if you guys
remember this but
um we asked why you're joining long now
people tell these incredible stories and
we've known for years because we get an
email every time someone joins we comes
along now member and we read each of
these reasons and it turns out long now
members are this is sort of incredible
group of people so you have artists and
Architects and parents and students and
designers and just everything in between
and um for years we've wanted to figure
out a way to Showcase this incredible
talent and it wasn't until the long now
member Summit in 2016 that we finally
got a chance to
um sort of have long now members take
the stage
um and that was the first long now
member ignite
um we loved it and we've kept up the
tradition ever since
um so without further Ado I'd like to
introduce our host for the evening
ignite talk founder Brady Forrest
[Applause]
thank you so much Andrew and thank you
to the long now and the club fugazi for
having us back here and yeah I'm not
just here to model your grandmother's uh
70s couch
um
I'm here to introduce uh these 13
amazing speakers that we have from
around the world and they are each going
to be giving an ignite talk and an
ignite talk is a very very specific
torturous format if you are a speaker
and super fun if you get to listen to it
so we lean in heavily on infotainment so
it is you know you take a very serious
topic but we make it fun we make it fast
and we pack it with stories
and so ignite started in 2006
and we had 25 speakers which is way too
many and each of those speakers gave a
five minute talk with 20 slides 15
seconds of slide that ought to advance
exactly that's what I mean by torturous
uh well over 10 000 people have done
them around the world
and you have the pleasure of being in
the room as the next 13 graduate into an
ignite class so let's just give them a
big round of applause
[Applause]
they have done a lot of work on this and
a couple of people have spent well over
half their work week on their talks over
the weekend uh
now our first Speaker though is an
ignite veteran she's like black belt
level ignite this might be like her
fourth or fifth depending on how you
count it and she is an artist an
entrepreneur she has main character
energy
and I highly recommend that you check
out our art on her Instagram conniverse
please welcome out
Connie yang
[Applause]
hello oh this incredible woman uh Wang
odd she is a Filipino tattoo artist and
she is on the cover of Vogue as you can
see and at 106 year old so it's this
year's April issue evoke she's the
oldest person to Grace the cover she has
been tattooing since she was 16 so she's
been doing it for 90 years that's crazy
people travel to vanilla Manila and then
go on a car ride for 12 hours in order
to get tattooed by her and she passes
this tradition on to younger women in
her generation that's really amazing so
if someone who's 106 can do that and I'm
like thinking I'm tired I don't know I'm
running out of time what do how do I get
things done that was a great story so I
started researching other people who
were in their 90s and 100 and seeing all
the different things that they do so
here are some of their stories starting
with a local Dorothy Lathan she lives in
San Francisco has been in Ocean Beach
for uh since the 1960s she keeps black
history alive in the city and was part
of creating the Museum of African
diaspora at the moad and she was also
one of the first black school teachers
Jack Kern he is a judo sensei in Great
Britain at 99 he just recently got us
his 10th Dawn which is the highest belt
that you can get for
um for Judo and that's makes him the
oldest person who's ever done that and
he moves every single day she is the
highest paid living female artist today
she lives in a psychiatric hospital by
choice in Tokyo and every day she walks
across the street to our art studio so
she can paint and actually create pieces
and she does this consistently it's
amazing Iris Apple she is an interior
decorator by trade has worked for nine
U.S presidents but really catapulted to
success and she was 84 into the solo
show at the Met and she is now a model
Muse influencer she um is oh something
jumped she's done awesome David
Attenborough what a living treasure he's
fantastic he has created over 100
documentaries created the Natural
History documentary I have to know it
today with beautiful cinematography
photography be and he has also won a
bafta and but we go on to DJ sumirak she
uh runs a dumpling shop by day and is a
DJ by night she DJs in Shinjuku
regularly has also djed in Paris and New
Zealand has dreams of DJing in New York
and that's her and her dumpling shop
that she's she's been doing for some 60
some years and she was in high school
she started DJing when she was in her
early 80s and has continued and that is
just fantastic I want to go see her I
hope everyone else does too Baddie
Winkle she's one of my favorites she um
lost her husband and her son and was
kind of in a slump and then her
granddaughter posted a photo of her on
Instagram and she became super popular
because she wears vibrant clothes is
kind of um really really loud and out
there and I was also like a like an
influencer like officially an influencer
I love that her bio says it's really
hard to see it says stealing your man
since 1928. it's really really great I
mean what a hero
I hope we can all be a little bit like
her and embrace that energy uh Dr Howard
Tucker he is the world's oldest
currently practicing doctor he's a
neurologist and he actually says
retirement is bad for cognitive
um cognitive ability it actually
decreases uh your your mind it actually
slows you down and here one of my
favorites uh my grandmother she moved
into a retirement community seven years
ago and instead of just slowing down and
doing nothing she started teaching
poetry to the other members of the
community and she wrote a book on poetry
her university did a documentary on her
it became super popular actually she's
on TV interviews she went viral in China
she came became known as poetry grandma
and got 150 million views it's really
it's really spectacular she kind of just
like well I'm just working hard and
doing the thing so it's I'm very happy
to be with her
so many great lessons overall keep
moving your body keep using your brain
keep learning keep being curious it's
never too late to start anything so many
examples they started very very late in
life think of yourself as young and stay
connected with your community
ending with Julia hurricane Hawkins who
started running when she was 100 years
old and it's the current record holder
for the her age group in the 100 meter
sprint and I love her quote I feel like
a shooting star and I don't know when
it's going to end well I'm so great
thank you everybody
[Applause]
thank you Connie and uh Grandma Yang if
you're watching this it is not too late
for you to do your first ignite talk
totally totally
uh our next speaker is an SF local he
flew in just for this he was away and
he's about to reveal a hobby he's been
working on for about eight years for the
very first time please welcome out altai
cabent
[Applause]
in 2015 I watched a TED Talk by a long
now board member David Eagleman it was
about how to create new senses for
humans
uh turns out we can only see a tiny
little slice of the whole
electromagnetic spectrum the whole the
rainbow that we can see is is that
little bit right there
I'm going to take you into the
ultraviolet today
all right fluorescence that's when you
shine a flashlight of one color on an
object and it then it glows a different
color think of like a you know shining
something on a 20 bill or like a
psychedelic poster okay in 1962 uh
natural fluorescence was found in a
glowing jellyfish in the in the 90s we
sequenced it we put it in another animal
and the people who did that got the
Nobel Prize for it
this is my childhood best friend Sam uh
he got his PhD in fluorescence and one
day he told me that he thought there's
like a lot of other stuff out there in
the ocean but we kind of brought the
jellyfish into the lab and forgot to go
back outside and keep looking
so I started thinking
so inspired by David Eagleman and Sam I
got scuba certified and I bought a black
light
it sat in a dryer for like six months
waiting for my next dive but then I was
like I wonder if things on land glow
so I started exploring I took my first
night hike
within 15 minutes or so I saw this
glowing moth and I was hooked
since then I've been like spent many
moons out there in the dark exploring
the world in ultraviolet light and I'm
finding all these crazy things like low
so
the problem is my photos were really
blurry back then enter my friend Henry
he's an amazing photographer travel
blogger uh he he encouraged me to get
better to get a better camera get better
lighting and taught me how to use it so
the photos started getting a little
better around now
uh the pandemic hit in 2020
I couldn't go scuba diving but I
realized oh I could find some ocean
creatures in tide pools so I started
exploring the California tide pools
um
this is one of my favorite discoveries
so these are Pacific mole crabs this is
right down the street from the Long
Island offices
um basically like when the when the
water comes in they stick up these like
feathery antenna they grab food and then
the water Retreats and they pull them
back in again it's really beautiful
all right I wanted to explore another
biome my friend Samson who's a biomimica
expert she opened the brego institute
for living design in the California
desert
so I did a creative residency down there
and I found this
all right remember Sam
well we're back in Maine for the
holidays he had heard about this otter
living at this pond in a cemetery so we
went and go to go see it with his family
I still don't know if Otter's glow but I
got an idea while I was out there
graveyard more like graveyard
like and glow like crazy
like crazy
everyone gets like a unique portrait of
you know painted by Nature after they
die and it's painted over millions or
not Millions but hundreds of years it's
a girl with a snail earring she was like
10 feet high it was hard to hard to
capture there's like sprinklers hitting
every 30 seconds the snails are moving
really fast
all right so what is lichen Lincoln is
actually a partnership between algae and
a fungus so it's not a single organism
it's a partnership so here the red is
the algae and the yellow is the Lichen
starting to starting to lichenize it
basically the algae makes makes uh food
from sunlight and the Lichen basically
creates a greenhouse for it turns out
this combination
is what has created soil they're the
like you know the Pioneers basically
they come they come to like harsh
Landscapes they break down the soil and
they can even survive in space
all right back down to earth here's a
here's some backstage
so I was in the cemetery I called up
Henry for advice he's on a beach in
Thailand with models
you can see me like really regretting my
life decisions here
so next stop Thailand
just kidding I went to the UK to find
some more graveyards
I wanted to find some older stuff
because like and grows very very slowly
as I told you
all right I bet now you're wondering
like you're starting to get curious I
hope you're maybe starting to let go of
some certainty starting to invite in
some curiosity maybe you're wondering
what around you close why things glow
how they glow or maybe you're imagining
your own tombstone
David Eagleman thinks that there's like
a bunch of Nobel prizes hidden out there
I agree I think there's a whole new
branch of science I think there's a
whole new genre of photography
and I think we have to find it
I think we have to find it collectively
because it's like too much for me so I
think we should start a citizen science
project to go explore the outdoors at
night so come join us at gloweth.org
thanks very much thanks
thank you altai for introducing us all
to the word graveyard
uh now our next speaker was kind enough
to film his talk in Canada you know the
long now has members all over the world
not all of them are able to be here so
we have four videos tonight so I ask you
to be a little extra quiet because it's
tough to hear uh but our next speaker is
a great Storyteller please welcome
Trevor halldundy
good evening everybody my name is Trevor
aldenby I'm from Toronto Canada I am
long now member number 378 and this is
are you now or will you ever be a fossil
when I said that word fossil uh each of
you probably had a different treasure
pop into your mind maybe it was
archeopteric Lucy the Australopithecus
or this marvelous petrified tree
but the truth is fossils are hiding a
little bit of a superpower you see
they're actually naturally occurring
time machines like a gadget they offer
us a magical experience at a
revolutionary price a free window into
the deep past and into the distant
future just holding one in your hand can
encourage you to more deeply consider
our legacies as individuals and as a
species
so what is a fossil anyway well whether
it's a brachia pond or a Brachiosaurus
no real relation fossils are the trace
or bodily remains of plants and animals
from the past that have been mineralized
into rocks
this process can take millions of years
and as a young man I was privileged
enough to be able to explore the tail
end of it in a landscape they don't
often show Canadians in the U.S travel
brochures the Badlands of Montana
in these Badlands as a scientific
research assistant I dug up 75 million
year old dinosaur eggs like the one you
see here turning them from science
objects into art objects by wrapping
them in plaster of Paris for the CT
scanners
and that summer I really understood what
it meant to see nature through multiple
ways of knowing scientific and artistic
that's summer in the Badlands gave me a
new lens on life's Evolution and on
myself they hit me right in the Wonder
Zone and if you were to look at the
world for a while through fossil frame
glasses like these what you might notice
is that our relationship to this static
geological process quite a bit more
Dynamic than it first seems
you see just as we're influencing the
Earth's atmosphere and biological
systems we're also influencing its
geological flows and systems of record
with our civilization
the odds of winding up a pristine Mona
Lisa fossil like this albertan
ankylosaur are increasingly unlikely and
that's if we have anything big like an
ankylosaur left to fossilize
you see in order to become a fossil you
have to first go through most of the
original Drake Equation the emergence of
life on a rocky planet near a star but
then there are additional bonus filters
for things like body composition the
speed of your burial the time you've
been left snug and undisturbed and
burial in the right acidic sediment
which give an ocean acidification is
getting harder to ensure
it used to be that taking a long walk of
a short pier in cement shoes was the
best way to get started with
self-fossilization but now we're not so
sure so as we become as Gods as Stuart
brand likes to say influencing the
natural cycles of fossilization what
would it be like to play Medusa
the truth is fossils have been a part of
many human cultures for a very long time
in the pre-canadian painter Kent
monkman's Works fossils are often a
crucial part of the stories and songs
that people share of the land
and in the works of other modern artists
and Architects we see unique vision and
inspiration for how fossilization might
show up in our future or what bodies or
descendants might be leaving behind
it isn't that hard to imagine us leaving
a Cambrian explosion of waste fossils in
our wake forks and filaments fused into
fractal patterns in the Rock like the
trilobites that we're familiar with
in stone
but for the early adopters among us
there is hope scientists and Engineers
are right now cracking the code on
synthetic fossilization turning a
million year process into a long weekend
set on broil in the lack
and it's not hard for me to imagine here
with the long now crowd that a member of
tonight's audience might be the first
contemporary human to be fossilized for
science or for art
we've covered a lot of ground here in
five minutes but next time you hold a
fossil in your hands or look at one in a
museum remember to feel the wonder they
are nature's time machines gateways into
the Art and Science of the long now
thank you
[Applause]
he is a guy who knows his audience look
at listen to those callbacks
um
our next speaker flew in just for this
talk this is her first time in San
Francisco
she's an entrepreneur for the past two
decades combining science art and
Technology into various projects and
companies and this next project is no
exception please welcome out Yael Schatz
[Applause]
hi everyone
I'm happy to be here
what if I told you that each and every
one of us is harboring an endless
treasure in our own home
every day we go about our lives crooked
meals spending time with loved ones and
leaving behind traces of ourselves in
the form of the dust in our home
Crumbs from the food we ate and smoke
residue from our cooking
fibers from our clothes hair and nail
fragments skin cells laundry and perfume
other molecules pets dander pollen fungi
minerals man-made pollution the
combination of these elements can be as
unique as a fingerprint
like pictures dust samples can only
provide a snapshot of a specific Moment
In Time but while pictures represent
visually dust contain material evidence
that opens more deciphering
opportunities
the science behind the dust is well
known archeology microbiology
allergology forensic and environmental
science
as we pair through the lens thus reveals
itself as a detailed story
at this point I got excited not only by
the material itself but also by the
combination of the two concepts of dust
in-house
dust is a concept rich in cultural and
social myth throughout human history
cloth in hand we erase proofs of our
mortality wrote the philosopher Michael
mother
the dust breeding photographed by Man
Ray resonance the dust's superpower to
conceal and reveal simultaneously
the concept of home is long time
embedded in human behavior
it can be seen as the foundation upon
which every other aspect of human life
is built
home is embedded into the physicality of
the house
that's from one house tells the story of
people
dust from several houses tells the story
of a city
thus from several cities tells the story
of a country and continents
so what are we going to do with all
these valuable information thrown under
our feet
the dust project collects a million dust
samples from homes worldwide in a short
period of time through a global
multilingual edutainment campaign
it yields three distinct archives that
offer a comprehensive view of human
activity in the environment over time
and a one-of-a-kind public experience of
shared testimony
an advanced digital platform enables you
to register free of charge based on
geolocation you will receive a
state-of-the-art envelope-sized dust
collection kit delivered to your
doorstep
in the week between receiving the kit
and taking the sample you might want to
bake your favorite cookies wear a shirt
with sentimental value or invite your
parents over
then with a collection sticker swipe
around areas of the house to get a
meaningful sample
your sample will be divided to three
parts to establish the dust archives
the mission of the archives is to create
a framework that enables the active
participation of the public in research
and education projects
the first archive consists of samples
kept by the participants at the home it
will serve as a personal connection
between them and the project for current
and future research as well as a unique
family heirloom
the second archive is hosted in a museum
it will serve as a more centralized and
and accessible data source and will
offer multiple ways to engage with the
project findings by the General Public
the third archives is stored inside the
dust Arc around passive satellite in the
shape of the earth placed in orbit 2 000
kilometer altitude from Earth as a
future archaeological artifact
with a 1.4 meter in diameter and a
highly reflective exterior duster can be
seen from Earth with regular telescopes
and it will stay in its orbit for at
least a century
maybe one day the arc will reach
futuristic deciphering technologies that
will recreate moments including tastes
smells and textures
if Humanity or the Earth will
dramatically change we may be leaving
behind not only names and pictures but
also a tangible experience from our life
story
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Yale
our next speaker was a designer in his
previous life but now works with
students on AI so as you can imagine
it's a fun time and changing all the
time
he's here to share some of his
experiments please welcome out Dave
elving
[Applause]
chat GPT is a superpower for teaching
and learning we're probably sick of
headlines like this but I believe this
is so and I believe it's especially true
for teaching and learning with code
and so what I'd like to share with you
today is my experience of teaching with
chat GPT in my interaction design class
at the California College of Art
but before I talk about new ways of
teaching and learning with code we need
to take a look at the way it's been
taught historically
so this is something that might look
familiar to you it's a hello world
script that writes two words onto a
screen and it looks complicated and
impenetrable and this is the way most of
us are exposed to coding and when I
first started learning how to code I had
a professor who wrote variables and
functions on the board with a Blackboard
I struggled my way to a d on the midterm
and I dropped out
so what would a new Hello World
experience in the world of AI look like
well it might be a little bit like this
this is a music visualization that I
developed using p5.js and it connected
to the accelerometer in an iPhone so
that as you moved the phone around the
shape would change and you could switch
between tracks
as you might expect this was a little
complicated coding was and I plopped my
students right into these hundreds of
lines of code and they were intimidated
but I told them I don't expect you to
learn every little piece of code and
every little variable instead we're
going to work together with chat GPT to
make this project your own and to do
that we're going to use natural language
that's what chat CPT really affords us
so I'll show you some of the things that
my students did once I gave them that
project chatgpd doesn't make the best
slides but one of the first things
students wanted to do was instead of a
still image in the background could I
have a moving video and this allowed me
to explain where the background was
rendered what an array is and how it
works
I had another student who didn't just
want one visualization in the center of
the screen he wanted two of them coming
together and apart like cell mitosis it
was complicated it'll make more sense if
I show you some examples of their work
so the first example I want to show you
is from Clarisse so you can see she has
videos playing in the background as she
moves the phone the track and the image
changes and she changed the particles
from circles to triangles which allowed
me to teach about classes and objects
my next student Abed he ditched the
whole notion of a circle and instead had
these waveforms growing together and
apart you'll see him as he moves his
phone he switches the track he may be
experiencing unique and his own and we
worked a lot with chat GPT to refine it
the last example I'll show you is from
wechin he wanted to have two
visualizations and of course swap out
the music and the image and was able to
make that work and as you see him moving
his phone you'll see the image and the
the waveforms kind of change he's
actually demonstrating right now the
volume goes down as you lower the phone
the volume comes up
they really liked this I got good
feedback my favorite feedback was the
coding parts are a bit too hard or some
of the class material is too difficult
because working with AI and machine
learning doesn't make things easier
teaching and learning is still hard
so far what does this mean so what five
takeaways to inform teaching and
learning that I gathered from this class
the first concept I want to share the
first idea is that Concepts
and problem solving are what really
matter Mastery doesn't nobody has to go
through memorizing syntax and doing that
hello world example anymore
instead we can use computational
thinking and natural language to create
with code
and this leads to the second takeaway I
want to share that exploration matters
more than Direction I could plot my
students in something really complex and
they could with chat GPT and my help
chart their own path not build piece by
piece in a directed way
but chat gbt isn't perfect
machine Learning Systems generate
examples not answers they still needed
my help to integrate the code that chat
EBT was giving them and I had to walk
around and work with them individually
to make it work doesn't work out of the
box which gets to the fourth point this
technology actually means that more is
required of teachers and students not
less
we've been empowered but with that
empowerment comes expectations we can do
more we have to teach more we have to
know more it's just different
and lastly artificial intelligence is
here we have a responsibility to teach
and learn with it chatgpt is in the news
now but many of you probably are already
aware of new models that are coming out
that are even more accessible and easy
to run
this is my class we were small but made
it a little bit easier to work with this
technology but I think these ideas scale
and will have long-term impact on how we
teach and learn going forward
so thank you very much and uh appreciate
it
thank you Dave our next speaker is
exploring a new type of clock one that's
been around for a millennia or more
uh a title clock please welcome or
please enjoy Sarah Sunday's video
[Applause]
thank you so much hi everyone
so 36.5 a durational performance with
the CE is a series of nine site-specific
performances and video artworks made in
collaboration with communities around
the world where I have stood in bodies
of water or a full title cycle between
12 and 13 hours each time
and it all began as a poetic response to
Hurricane Sandy hitting New York City in
October of 2012 because what happened
was I suddenly understood just how
vulnerable we were we know that
civilizations come and go intellectually
but could my beloved City disappear in
my lifetime what was water trying to
tell us about the Future these were the
questions I was asking I kept imagining
this little artist or any person really
running around the city trying to make
ends meet and the city's just sinking
beneath her feet
and I kept on thinking about this
parallel between the struggle for an
individual to survive on a daily basis
and the struggle for Humanity to survive
in the face of the climate crisis
and then nine months later I'm up in
Maine and I realized that the tides
could function as a metaphor for sea
level rise
so one day I walk out I low tide and I
let the water rise up to my chin and
then I let it go back down again over
the course of 12 hours and 48. and I
didn't know if I would make it through
this whole cycle but there was an
important moment when the water was high
and I understood in my body just how
connected we all are and I thought if
I'm this little person in New York City
thinking about these things what is
someone in Bangladesh or Kenya thinking
about and I promised myself that if I
made it through the cycle I would create
this in collaboration with communities
around the world and so that's what
happened nine years nine bodies of water
hundreds of collaborators thousands of
participants a global project was a
local approach and here's what I learned
I learned about deep listening to the
water the more the human world the
people and all other living beings who
live near the water and from my
indigenous collaborators around the
world I learned about decentering the
human or just one species after all and
reframing water as our tin in relation
rather than as a resource
and they really taught me about engaging
in Daily practice of gratitude
reciprocity asking permissions in
relation to the water the land and and
stirs
and I learned about deep time and
long-term thinking my work has always
been based around ideas of time
questions about expanding and
Contracting time but with 36.5 I started
to really look at the ancient past in
order to try to understand the long term
but perhaps not so distant future we
have with Rising Seas
and then on an individual scale I
learned about feeling time as a sensory
experience because it's one thing to
consider climate change intellectually
and it's a completely different thing to
feel the water rise on your body over
the course of a day or to witness this
happening because we know everything is
temporary and we're only here on this
planet for a short amount of time and I
try to recognize the Beauty and the
terror of this fact
what can I do in my short little flip of
a life and for me it's about tracking
time literally and symbolically on my
body and then connecting with as many
people as possible inviting them to
experience this with me in this act I
find some hope
so now that the performance is for 36.5
are complete there's several outgrowth
exhibitions and book Etc things
happening and but I'm following one new
thread to explore ideas about living in
ecological time more of the time so I'm
curious to see if I can possibly let go
of the mechanical clock and find a title
clock in my body I'm trying to train
myself to sense the water levels at all
times and tune my body to live in title
time even when I'm not at the water's
edge what can happen if we synchronize
the salty water in our bodies to the
Salt Water that's hovering seven tenths
of the planet could this help us be
better prepared and adapt to a future
with more water
what if we just need to tune in
thank you so much
[Applause]
you know so often for me meditations
like this on the earth like what Sarah
did and what altai gave us just really
kind of brings together what the long
now is about
without appreciating this Earth that
we're on thank you Sarah uh our next
speaker is quite the communicator that's
what she does professionally and it's
also her passion so today she's going to
be talking about oral history which is
something I'm sure we've all had to
study throughout our days please welcome
out Diane Tate
[Applause]
the people of the book you may have
heard this expression before regarding
the Jewish people it's because many
Jewish people have a deep love and
reverence for the Hebrew scriptures the
book of Torah but actually it's somewhat
of a misnomer when it comes to the
Jewish people because the Jewish faith
for millennium for Generations was
passed down from one generation to the
other verbally it's an oral tradition in
fact the Jewish faith is one of many
many oral Traditions that impact our
culture and many other cultures tonight
we're going to look at one type of oral
tradition oral history
so first of all what is oral history
well it's a way to get at historical
events through the lens of individual
experiences through interviews it's a
way to capture what happened with
people's memories and perceptions of
what transgressed in the past
but why do we care well often the
official historical narrative leaves out
critical voices and perspectives many
times marginalized disenfranches
disenfranchised voices are left out at
the narrative and so it gives us an
incomplete picture of History
10 years ago no actually 13 years ago
almost to the day Frank Gavin an
historian came to the long now and
shared his vision his perspective of
History which is that horizontal history
many factors come into play to affect
the historical narrative well I would
posit that oral history is the human
lens it's the overlay among all these
variables to give meaning and
explanation to what happens in the
history it's sort of like an accounting
statement with footnotes they make it
make sense
Steven Spielberg totally understood the
power of oral history when he was making
Schindler's List he realized that there
were so many human stories that needed
to be told not only to complete the
picture of the Holocaust but to help us
connect with it as humans and he knew
that was important so he partnered with
USC to start the showa foundation they
collect thousands of Holocaust Survivor
stories so that not only do we know more
about the Holocaust but we understand on
a human level what it meant and we
learned from it
Isabelle Wilkerson uses oral history
significantly in her study of the Great
Migration She interviewed over 1200
people and did a deep dive interviewing
intensely three of these people between
1915 and
1917-70 over 6 million African Americans
left the South to other parts of the U.S
to get better Economic Opportunity but
especially to escape the racial regime
of Jim Crow
so
some of the folks that she focused on
included Ida May Brandon gladney
she was living in Mississippi with her
husband when her husband's cousin was
nearly killed for stealing some turkeys
so pregnant with two small children her
and her husband left for Chicago to find
opportunity instead they found a gladded
labor market and they were competing not
only with other migrants but with
immigrants they became the bottom of the
pecking order again
it was not pretty
George Foster Starling is another person
that Isabelle Wilkerson spoke with he
was born in Florida and college educated
and soon learned and understood that
they were being exploited in the fields
and so he organized his co-laborers to
demand more money he was nearly killed
so he went to New York City
there he didn't see white signs or
colored signs and he could go to a bar
and get served but the bartender would
make it very clear that he wasn't
welcome by Smashing the glass loudly
upon his departure
and finally Dr Robert Joseph Pershing
Foster was an accomplished physician and
surgeon in World War II but when he
returned to Monroe Louisiana he learned
that he couldn't even do a simple
tonsillectomy so he went to Los Angeles
so he could practice medicine but sadly
even the journey there began to reveal
the kind of obstruction and resistance
he would face
driving up to a hotel and a vacancy sign
becomes a No Vacancy sign the subtle
rejection and exclusion continued all
these stories tell us that the Great
Migration while leading to Economic
Opportunity also didn't close
the limitations and the oppression that
many black people faced and because
these are human stories we can relate to
them on a personal level and reflect
so I would ask you who in your backyard
has lived through an historical event
small or large what are their
perceptions their memories what did they
experience and what can they add to the
historical narrative
get curious and do some research and
then turn on your phone and ask them
some questions and capture it and if
they agree share it with others so that
others not only have a fuller picture of
history but they connect with it as
humans
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Diane our next speaker has
been in robotics for several decades and
it's going to share her deep thinking on
the ethics of AI and Robotics please
welcome out Andre kieh
g'day everybody having these talks been
amazing let's hear it for everyone yeah
I do not want to follow them but I'm
just going to State the blindingly
obvious the world is burning
it's hotter than it has ever been in
recorded history our recorded history
what's more
the last time the world was this hot
people didn't exist
that's not a good omen
the biggest problem is we know what the
solution is we just need to stop
stop emitting 30 gigatons of greenhouse
gases stop polluting stop rolling out
polluting Technologies just stop
well let's ask the ludites how well that
worked out for them okay stopping not a
strong point let's be radical and
embrace technology I'm team robot all
the way
with robots with drones in particular
and thermal imaging we can detect heat
leakage
particularly from old buildings which
are responsible for 99 of the heat waste
and we can't retrofit them
that's why the department of energy ran
the e-robot prize to find robots that
could go into ethics and War cavities
and under the floor and replace all of
that insulation
it's why 3D printing is a really great
answer we're eliminating Transportation
costs and waste where reducing waste
this is Texas uh icon is Building 100 3D
printed homes there California Mighty
buildings but NASA had the Centennial
challenge
about six years ago
to use local
materials mud
for Mars over our homes here but moving
on to transport a self-driving cars tip
of the iceberg just a tiny little part
of what we can achieve with autonomous
mobile robot Technologies it's all about
self-driving cargo and these are all
electric vehicles right
already the major retailers know this
this is jd.com same thing at ocado or
Amazon or Walmart
but what's been exciting over the last
five years is the plethora
of new autonomous mobile robots roaming
out into the world you probably don't
see them but we're rethinking how we
move materials changing the first mile
changing the Last Mile and all the miles
in between and before you say well hey
electricity isn't all that's cracked up
to be right
we are introducing solar power faster
than ever before because we're using
robots to help construct solar farms and
to keep them clean
we have new battery technologies coming
this one I love it is carbon-based
plant-based it is already in commercial
deployment multiple units last year and
2025 the first fully
eco-sustainable battery
Alpha Garden you probably know Ken
Goldberg it's a project of his up at UC
Berkeley to show that Robotics and AI
can perform organic multi-crop tending
as well as people can
farmers are embracing robotic technology
and this is not the massive Machines of
our previous agricultural systems these
are smaller lighter
machines from the actual tractors in use
today to new devices like this lovely
little dandelion robot from France
and that allows us to get into 20 of the
arable area that is currently not
utilized and to stop the soil compaction
that is destroying our ability to use
the land
we can now do proper regenerative
practices in agriculture with the use of
robots including solar powered wind sail
robots like agent just up the coast here
let us not forget
animal
happy cows
cows have been looked after 24 7 by
robots and you know what their hormone
levels show that they are happy and so
does the milk so all I can say is forget
that AI apocalypse there is nothing that
the smartest artificial intelligence can
do that stupid humans haven't already
buggered up
embrace the robots
let us save the planet with robots Okay
Viva robotopia
[Applause]
you know I feel like with Andrea you'd
you'd be rooting for Arnie in the first
Terminator
um
our next speaker is a Storyteller by day
Architect by night and does some fun
urban planning experiments in his home
on Cyprus please enjoy his video
foreign
so nine years ago I quit my job as a
cryonics you know for those people who
want to freeze themselves for a thousand
years hoping to wake up in a better
world
my job was to make sure there are frozen
bodies would stay safe and sound for all
that long
no pressure right I mean how do you even
design the building to last for a
millennium well oh no that's a zombie
apocalypse or a giant Media or another
Global pandemic
how do you guarantee your clients will
end up as popsicles for some Alien
Invaders or in a zoo
I mean given that nothing lasts forever
what is a literally sustainable design
well good luck finding any answers on
the internet
most of what you'll find are a bunch of
green washing products programs that
claim to be eco-friendly but they're
actually just as bad if not worse than
status quo I mean they promise to have a
net zero impact but they don't say yeah
they measure that or what they do with
the waste or how they exploit the
workers or how they private politicians
I mean they don't care about your future
they primarily care about their problem
what maybe just about give up though was
when I was working on a huge map for San
Antonio a map that showed all the
infrastructure planned and the existed a
map that revealed a shock and Truth 25
of the pipes underground they're old
they're rotten they're leaking cracking
bursting contaminating water supply they
were violating the Clean Water Act and
the city was facing like a billion
dollar fine fix how do you explain that
how do you tell them they have to folk
over billions of dollars for something
they never asked never see never care
about how do you tell them they have to
pay for flush and toilets
you know so that's the burning question
how could we create a truly sustainable
human you know world where we don't ruin
everything for ourselves and our kids
however we don't have to worry about
climate change solution resource
depletion Extinction
a world where we can have a harmonious
story between us of nature
after a year I was so stressed off by
this question I decided to seek some
spiritual guidance I ended up cooking
breakfast for this Tibetan mom he was
very nice very wise very bold
but all the scrambled eggs and coffee he
asked me what was bothered me what did I
want to learn I babbled on about my
interest in impermanence fractal
geometry psychology historically and he
stopped and he said storytelling that's
it that research needs to be done
so I did I quit my job in the back of my
cats and I moved to Cyprus here I read a
lot of books and articles and I came
across this amazing story about two
Australian researchers who were
following a song now a song Allah turns
out it's like an epic GPS the Aboriginal
people have used to navigate the land
they sing the stories and if they're
going in the right direction the
landforms along the way correspond to
the characters in the story
okay so the year is 2014 and these
researchers are walking along singing
their little hearts out when suddenly
they're standing in the sea they thought
they messed up somehow maybe they took a
wrong turn at the Berlin bush
but then they realized maybe the song
continues under the water
and sure enough they found the rest of
the land box that merged in the sea on
oceanic charts this SOG line was so old
it dated back to the last ice age where
the sea level was established
this song line had survived for like 10
500 years passed down by word mouth for
at least 500 Generations
now that's longer than any trialx
probably
more fun
well this blew my mind how can I use
this ancient technology to shape our
future maybe we could leverage
continuity going backwards to go
forwards but how can we tell our stories
to the land like that and make them
stick
well it turns out it's just that so you
need to map your stories you know the
stories you tell yourself or your
friends or your therapists no meaningful
Stories the stories that make up who you
are where you come from all those
stories episode and a setting can be
mapped
imagine our stories like a tapestry I
mean we laid them out on the land we
could see other threads of each other's
stories intertwine how they target each
other how they harmonize and with this
knowledge we can spend no tales that
build upon the old you know like weaving
New threads to fill in the worn holes of
our towns
and mathemat stories isn't just for
personal Insight we could use them to
guide decisions about our neighborhoods
climate immigration Business Development
isolation we can make sure that
everything we do is in harmony with our
stories or at least not contradicted
now just to live together we need to
know where each other are coming from
the average for people of Australia
showed me that the stories mixed with
the land can last for thousands of years
so so using stories of the people here
in famagusta I made a prototype with a
map of stories you know that you know we
and our descendants could adapt and
evolve world
stories that could last but ten thousand
years or more
now we all know there are gaps in the
structures that support our society in
order to enable communities to plug
those gaps we need to build a narrative
infrastructure now one that Maps stories
and communities across the world with
narrative tools and GIS we can create a
narrative infrastructure for the future
a future that's not on ice but a lie
with stories
thank you very much
thank you Jason
our next speaker we've got three talks
left our next speaker loved camping so
much that she's dedicated her career to
it she started the website hip Camp when
I get a cheer yeah
[Applause]
and her website has unlocked millions of
Acres of private lands for camping and
if I was to sum up her talk is if you
want a Green Planet you should camp so
please welcome out Alyssa ravaccio
[Applause]
hello good evening uh thank you for
having me my name is Alyssa ravazio I
love camping I love camping so much I
created a company to get more people
outside and we've opened access to about
5 million acres of land on this very
beautiful planet we call Earth
um it's a really awesome planet
um it has this really unique ability to
sustain life which is really important
to all of us here and to all of the
beans on Earth and something that I
think about all the time is that our
planet's ability to sustain that life is
dropping rapidly and this is happening
on our watch during our lifetimes
um and it's a real tragedy
um this is mostly cause the leading
cause is habitat loss and habitat
destruction which really happen as a
direct result of actions we take
consciously and I think it's just a
really
um yeah tragic Showcase of our cultural
values
however there is a bold beautiful Vision
known as half Earth which I'm sure we're
mostly familiar with here the Lake Road
EO Wilson theorized that if we can set
aside at least one half of the earth we
can sustain life on Earth for a long
time into the future now the main way we
do this is through purchasing land and
purchasing conservation easements on
that land which is really effective at
stopping development but has a major
problem which is that there's no ongoing
system or funding to support the
maintenance and stewardship of that land
there's a big problem even with that
acknowledgment the world is moving
forward here which is exciting last year
at caught 15 190 countries signed an
agreement to go for 30 by 2030 the U.S
did not sign but by executive order is
participating this is deputy secretary
of biodiversity Jen Norris that's a real
title and she's leading California which
is leading the world on this we're on
track for 20 five percent already and 30
by 2030. I was invited to participate at
half Earth Day recently and really the
purpose of that discussion was to say
like how are we going to solve this
major challenge of supporting half the
Earth long into the future because half
of the earth is a lot of land and the
future is a really long time
and the perspective I bring to this
conversation is that if you look at the
land today the reality is that most of
it is privately held and especially when
we look at what's public today and
getting to half Earth private land and
the future of those lands is really
where the fate of our biosphere hangs
today and what's interesting is that
this land is owned by people and people
react to incentives and the future of
conservation Aldo Leopold said it well
is really going to come down to how do
we reward the people who currently have
these lands and this is where outdoor
recreation comes in generally in camping
specifically outdoor recreation creates
a really powerful economic engine that
rewards people who are keeping their
lands open and free and natural fun
places to play I had this experience
personally I went to meet a Rancher a
few years back who'd started hosting
campers and the first thing she did was
hand me this letter and she said you
know I hate this letter they want to buy
my land and build a big hotel but I'm
terrified I'm going to have to call them
except now that I've got camping this is
junk mail I don't need it I know I can
take care of my land these people want
to do the right thing I'm yet to meet
anybody who takes care of the land who
doesn't want to leave it better than
they found it but they need to have the
economic support to do that not only do
people use this income from outdoor
recreation to keep their land they
actually proactively invest it the
majority of people who are earning
income from camping proactively invest
in stewardship think Native species
rewilding restoring stream beds
outdoor recreation also plays a big role
in the solution here by changing culture
another great deal Wilson concept
biophilia we have an innate love for
nature we get outside we can't help but
fall in love with it and we protect what
we love Chris Tompkins said that really
well she also holds a distinct privilege
of being the human who's protected the
most land on Earth at 15 million Acres
which is a lot and so we have to get
more people outside to fall in love with
nature and develop that passion for
protecting it so in summary outdoor
recreation can play a huge role in
solving this challenge that stands
between us and half Earth by developing
sustainable scalable systems that can
support the land economically and create
a culture that continues to encourage
that so I encourage you all to get
outside and next time you're sitting out
enjoying the beauty of our Earth under
the stars please know that you are
contributing to a beautiful future for
our planet in a really positive way
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Alyssa our next
speaker is a best-selling author of the
book A sense of the world it's about a
blind man who traveled the world fought
the slave trade went to Africa Frozen
the Arctic but today he's here for a
slightly more tongue-in-cheek topic
please welcome Jason Roberts
[Applause]
these words are the title of my
presentation followed by my name
um now you'll know what it doesn't say
bye Jason Roberts because in early 21st
century San Francisco you don't need to
do that it's implied
now I just spent 15 seconds telling you
the obvious and here's why I am a writer
I'm a writer of Books mostly non-fiction
books mostly historical non-fiction
books which means I'm also in a story
and kind of deal with the past now there
are a lot of challenges in terms of
dealing with the past
um they're texts that are lost or texts
that are biased uh translations that are
wrong some things that can't be
translated like this is the Voynich
manuscript and there's lots of lost
content
but the worst thing is that encapsulated
in the phrase it goes without saying
so much history actually is lost to us
not because the historical record is
gone but because it was never in this
Oracle record in the first place
why waste useful papyruses or anything
like that to say what's completely
obvious what's common knowledge these
are Roman dodecahedrons these are these
12-sided metal and stone objects that we
find in hundreds of ancient Roman sites
throughout Europe what are they we don't
know
we have plenty of theories they might be
fishing weights they might be musical
instruments they might be early Dungeons
and Dragons but the the point is that we
have to guess because the Romans they
were so commonplace that the
instructions and how to use them were
common players here's garam now the
Romans loved garum it's this condiment
they used it on everything it was their
mayonnaise and mustard and salt and
pepper all put together their entire
economy was built around it but we don't
know what it was except for the fact
that it seems to have involved fish
now we have plenty of Roman recipes in
fact the word recipe is Latin for first
you take like first you take a fish but
of the hundreds if not thousands of
recipes none of them is for the most
common object
here's another thing um there in the
Bible itself there's this character
called the disciple whom Jesus loved
which you think would be kind of a big
deal and Jesus thought he was a big deal
he sat next to him in the Last Supper in
fact at some point Jesus puts his head
in his lap it's a very important person
he was adopted by the Virgin Mary he's
the one who discovers the resurrection
he's granted immortality and he's one of
the authors of the Bible but for the
other authors of the Bible they thought
nobody needed to say who he was his
identity went without saying
now here's a big question why are they
called buggies when you think about it
that's kind of a strange name for a
horse and carriage I thought it might be
a very interesting answer so I posed it
to the champion of interesting answers
chat GPT
no it says it says here um that um it
originally referred to a frightening
Specter hob Garden Goblin blah blah blah
refers to a small lightweight vehicle
associated with blah blah blah the point
is that that was all wrong
I asked the question because I knew that
there is no answer to it and when I went
and then it actually started
hallucinating the answer now
for that reason I believe I need to
propose something called DOI the
depository of obvious information
for future Generations let's create
let's say the unsaid that idea that it
goes without saying is not necessary
because honestly uncommon knowledge
it becomes common knowledge and vice
versa most importantly here's a question
what is the FAA definition of flight see
some things aren't quite trivial it
turns out there is no definition for
flight there's a definition for flight
time which begins when when a vehicle
pushes forward for the purpose of flight
but there is no actual definition of
flight which is interesting because it
turns out that you know a qualified
Pilots need certain degrees of flight
time your body could have 100 degrees of
flight time but actually no five minutes
of actual flight or here's another
example is sudden death I looked on
Wikipedia I looked everywhere on the
internet there's no definition that
describes that no actual death is
involved
and in fact I asked this question what
does the phrase my Ultimate Team
encountered sudden death mean
something went wrong ah
if it's going to confuse AI it's going
to confuse future Generations
so you know this is the thing confusion
is actually useful instead of trying to
gloss over these things instead of
having AI you know hallucinate the
answers how about it identifies where
those gaps of knowledge are it could
work with us to identify those gaps and
basically create the depository of
obvious information so join me won't you
join me in saying
maybe you don't know what I mean maybe
you want to
maybe we can bridge that Gap thank you
very much
[Applause]
all right we're on our penultimate talk
and uh Natalia Vasquez is basically
leads idios Global uh climate foresight
work and today she's going to take us on
a tour of 2030. please welcome or please
enjoy the Italian Vasquez video
[Applause]
for the last six months I've been
visioning climate Futures with about 50
designers at Innovation consultancy idea
because I believe butering will be a
powerful tool in our Collective climate
action
so come with me to 2034 let's check it
out
last night I went down and I watched the
offshore wind turbines in the bay you
know the ones they made into sculptures
so folks would let them be built by the
hundreds and looking up I could see all
the satellites between the Stars
analyzing their methane leaks and
biomatter loss really beautiful
I freelance and auditing greenhouse
gases so I'll get a ping to check out a
site where there might be a leap or
where reforestation might be working and
then I'll take a bunch of photos and
they use it for emissions accounting and
training the spatial image analysis
my last gig was verifying the algae
bloom happening off the coast of Chile
and since the government had offered a
cleanup bounty to contract to the
biodiversity credit there was A Rush of
folks there to harvest and salsa the
bioplastics market
and with the algae bloom feeding the
global bioplastics market there's been
so much more algae-based product in
shops right now I just got my Ikea my
selling stool and lamp two and I've been
redecorating my apartment in the
regenerative style which has been a lot
easier because of the tax credits that
we all have but you know onions
consumption and we're all trying to
reduce while we land this transition
from fossil fuel production within our
individual Carbon ration and I still
sometimes buy stuff you know it's hard
to change
but
things have also gotten more expensive
with the Global Tax from the ministry of
regeneration that goes to payout
reparations to climate impacted
countries
I've been trying to stay away from stuff
with a carbon rating of less than three
but often that's the good stuff and I
did get some fines this week so I joined
one of these consumer anonymous groups
it's been helpful to just kind of talk
to people we're also struggling in the
shift to consume less and to shift from
single youth to reusable
fortunately that's been a little bit
easier lately and that's largely because
of the universal reusable packaging
system that we're all now required
and I love how I can pick up takeout now
in an airport in Tokyo and return that
container in any store in the world
including here in San Francisco my home
is getting a little full of these
standardized packages but I actually
love that the the universal reusable
packaging mandate killed custom
container shapes and labeling that now
all the brand is sort of expressed
stitchably
um and it feels like I'm actually
learning a lot more and I just have less
stuff to deal with in my house
and since they halted the fashion
production and we're all using uh we're
supposed to be refusing clothes for the
next hundred years I rent new outfits
with my rent anywhere card from any
store anywhere in the world and it's fun
to see all the people who have owned it
in the last 10 years as well anyway last
night after I watched the wind turbines
I picked up my car which I left charging
these supercharged street lights and I
made a few bucks on the way home
swapping out my battery at one of the um
swap Stations between here and Marin
honestly this whole decarbonized grid
movement has been great my apartment is
Tiny and like most people now I've got
one table for cooking charging heating
of space in the gas ERA this would have
taken so much more space but now that
we've electrified everything
my life is full of simpler things and
like everyone else my neighborhood is
part of a distributed energy Community
plugged into the city grid but reducing
energy all day Guided by software to
help us optimize production with the
weather and more and more life has been
like that individuals functioning as an
ecosystem so back to 2023 the world you
just visited is part of an effort we've
been doing to create speculative
conditions for the future with
industrial designers emerging
Technologies anthropologists and
certainly we are mostly wrong about the
future but that's not the point
designing our way out of the climate
crisis must consider future scenarios
and friends we are short on Vision the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change has a 40 page PDF of text and
really text is most of what you get if
you search for climate futures
how can we be expected to derive without
the destination in mind
numbers just don't shift hard we also
need to be able to collectively picture
shifts down to the minutia down to the
mundane and you need to be able to get
excited about that picture in our minds
this is one of the most widely
circulated non-dystopic visualized
climate features and it's from a yogurt
company shoguni the fictive community
has brought us some wonderful books and
recently a TV series but we need more we
need more to picture and think about
together so we've been sketching the
human angle of Futures behaviors
products rituals and our goal has been
to create stimula visually Rich enough
to get wheels turning and to light a
fire under the organizations that we
work with and ultimately to start for a
conversation and we need more
one for each life for your life what
does your life look like in a climate
impacted 2030 no really what just
flashed in your brain
let's get more of those Visions born and
out into the world stay tuned
[Applause]
thank you Natalia uh so this is our last
talk and you are all welcome to stay and
hang out we have a beverage minimum you
can help us out with that uh you can
also reconnect it's been a while since
we had one of these uh but now we're
going to welcome out our final speaker
she's a designer and she's going to talk
about
what happens when the medical system
intercepts or uh intersects with our
Humanity we'll use welcome out Natasha
Blum
[Applause]
famous last words are notorious for not
being able to predict the future well
but they do convey our inner World
magnificently
my name is Natasha and I lead an
innovation consultancy called blumline
where we study people and culture to
design smarter Kinder wiser futures
my shelter in place did not include any
sourdough or much sleep but it did
include working with the healthcare
Innovation Community to try to prop up
the system with covid-19 response
through the design thinking lens
we rapidly created a brand and recruited
volunteers for PPE challenges masks
blood donation but the real challenge
was the rising death toll and the end of
life which was really at the center of
the entire pandemic
front line
caregivers were required to make
decisions for people they had barely met
and required to resuscitate even when it
would cause irreparable harm which most
people didn't know coming in without
advanced directives
the team and I worked on uncovering
insights and we realized that a journey
map was really the best way to tell this
story to illustrate to people the
pathway of what happens when you get
coveted and you go into the hospital
become intubated and are likely
unconscious it's not the best way to
advocate for yourself or your agency
and a lot of this wasn't tremendously
unfamiliar working with chronic
conditions and behavior change
but we had a unique Moment In Time the
pandemic actually created an opening we
call it a Moment of Truth where
possibility
um
can become a reality but people still
need Solutions so we created one called
famous last words
that was set in three parts life death
and dying and it was a collective
self-discovery ritual
which means looking at self and values
first but in the company of other people
where we can actually learn relational
Dynamics
about
burial
mycelium suit
the ash Cannon by Hunter S Thompson and
Tibetan Sky rituals all examples of more
creative ways of thinking about the end
of life which is something that we don't
usually do we usually avoid it
and treat it as something to fight
against
for me this was motivated by my
grandmother uh whose end of life wishes
I know very well she has multiple dnrs
plastered all over her house
but her emotional side is a little
harder I think she has a hard time
understanding that she might have a
right to think more creatively about
aging
care comes in many forms like the warm
water glove and the Brazilian ICU that
comforted a covid patient or the
Butterfly Kisses for a cancer patient
that were attracted by orange juice
exploring different cultures
and different settings is essential you
know we can participate in revelry
or we can talk about death through the
medical system through paperwork which
sounds super fun
or we can bring Beauty and
Rouse courage through that
and bring the mystical back into our
experience
it isn't by avoiding death that we get
more comfortable with it
it's by confronting it but in a generous
way not in a deaf porn sense
and one of the best questions I find for
this is asking who is the you of now
because certainly none of us are who we
were three years ago
and thank goodness
I'm not
sometimes you walk through a portal you
don't even see coming
and that's the beauty of thinking about
Futures we just don't know
it makes it difficult to think about
death because we write things like final
wishes
but nothing's final we have to come back
to it again and again we have to slow
down
and we have to be willing to revisit it
and to go into spaces that can teach us
more than we think they can
so I encourage you
to explore Collective self-discovery
with me
and let me know how you're getting
creative
[Applause]
yeah last time I made the mistake of
putting her in the middle
and that just didn't work all right we
are done you are welcome to stay uh I
want to thank Club fugazi for having us
thanks to the long
[Applause]
thank you very much to the long now it's
such a joy to do this with you
[Applause]
and thank you to our wonderful speakers
for putting up with all these directions
[Applause]